PROFESSOR: So in
this short segment,
we'll talk about some
relational properties
that I call mapping properties.
They can also be referred to
as archery [? on ?] relations.
This segment is
mostly vocabulary.
There are a half
a dozen concepts
and words that are
standard in the field
and that one needs to know to be
able to do discrete math and so
on.
The applications will come
in the next short segment
where we start applying
these properties to counting.
Although, there'll
be a punchline
about counting at the
end of this segment.
So let's go back or proceed.
And remember that
a binary relation
is a thing with three parts.
It's got a domain
illustrated as A here,
a codomain
illustrated as B here,
and relationship's
an association
between domain elements and
codomain elements indicated
by the arrows, the
arrows being called
the graph of the relation.
And we already observed one
aspect of archery and arrows
that the concept
of a function could
be captured by saying
that there was less than
or equal to 1 arrow out of
every element in the domain.
That implied that there
was a unique other end
of an arrow out
of a domain point
called the value of that
point under the relation
which is in fact a function F.
So F of green
equals magenta where
there is an arrow out
of a green element.
But in this picture--
as is typical--
not every domain element--
not every green dot--
has an arrow out if it.
So this would be an illustration
of a partial function
where F of a green element
isn't always defined
if there's no arrow out.
Well, the general idea
of archery relations
pursues this function
idea that basically we're
going to classify relations
according to-- first,
how many arrows come
out of domain elements?
Really, in three categories.
The relations where
there's at most
one arrow out of
every domain element,
there's exactly one arrow
out of every domain element,
or there's at least one arrow
out of every domain element.
And symmetrically, we're going
to classify codomain relations
with respect to codomain
in the same way-- relations
where every codomain element
has greater than or equal to 1.
Arrow in has exactly
one arrow in,
or at most, one arrow
in is the other part
of the classification.
And various combinations
of these things
have standard name,
which it turns out
that you'll need to know.
So we'll lead you through them.
OK.
So let's begin with the
idea of a total relation.
Total relation means there's
at least one arrow out
every domain element.
So if you look at this
picture, it's not quite total
yet because there are
two green domain elements
with no arrows out of them.
So I've just
highlighted them in red,
and we can fix this by
making them disappear.
Now I'm left with
a total relation.
Every domain elements has at
least one arrow coming out
of it.
So that's what makes it total.
Another way to say
total is to say
that if you look at the
inverse image of the codomain,
it is equal to the domain.
That means if you take all
the arrows that are coming out
of the domain and
you turn them around
and you look at all the things
that have arrowheads into them,
it's the entire domain.
So that's what R inverse
of B-- a nice, slick way
to say it using relational
operators and sets related
to applying relations.
So total and function means that
there's exactly one arrow out,
and that's probably the most
familiar case of functions.
And lots of fields just assume
that functions are total,
but the truth is that
there often is not total.
And people aren't careful about.
So let's look at a
calculus-like example.
Here's a function g that
takes a pair of reals
and returns a real.
It maps the real plane
into the real line.
And the definition of it is g
of x, y is 1 over x minus y.
Now, the domain
of this function g
is in fact all the
pairs of reals.
That's what it means to say
that it goes from R cross R--
shorthand R squared--
to the codomain R.
The codomain is the
set of all reals.
But this g is obviously
not total because 1 over 0
is not defined, which means
that on the 45 degree line,
g is not defined.
g of r, r is not defined.
So g in fact, is
not a total function
even though it's familiar.
And you'd not worry about
partial functions normally.
You wouldn't notice
that this was partial
because you're not used to
paying attention to that.
OK.
Let's look at a
slight variation.
This is function g 0 that goes
from some unspecified domain.
I'll specify it in a
minute to the reals.
It has exactly the same formula
g of x, y is 1 over x minus y.
But now, I'm going to tell
you that the domain-- instead
of being all the reals-- is the
reals except for that 45 degree
line.
I just want to get
rid of the bad points
and not worry about them.
The minute I do that, I
have these two functions
relations that have the same
graph but different domains.
And the result is that I've
removed from the domain of g
all the bad points.
I'm left with a
total function g 0.
OK.
Let's keep going.
The next concept
is of a surjection,
and that's a
relation where there
is at least one arrow into
every point in the codomain.
There's at least one arrow
into every point in B.
Well, again this is a picture
where that doesn't quite
work because there's at least
one bad point there-- there it
is in red-- that doesn't
have an arrow in.
So let's fix things again
by making it disappear.
Now I'm left with a surjective
relation, or a surjection,
because in fact, everything
in the codomain in B
has at least one arrow coming.
Everything's the
endpoint of an arrow.
So likewise, we can say
in terms of set operations
that R is a surjection if and
only if the image of the domain
is the codomain.
Or still another way
to say it is-- if
and only if the
range of the function
is its entire codomain.
Remember, the
range of the points
that are hit--
that's R of A-- it's
not always equal
to the codomain.
But when it is, that is
what makes it a surjection.
All right.
Injections-- another variation
on the theme-- an injection
is a relation where
there is at most one
arrow into every
element in the codomain.
So looking at this picture now,
this is not quite an injection
because there are at
least two points here
that have more than one
arrow coming into them.
That's what keeps it
from being an injection.
So let's fix that by deleting
a couple of those edges
that are crowding up
points, and now I'm
left with a situation where,
in fact, everything in B
has at most one an
arrow coming in.
And so I'm showing you a
picture of an injection.
And the final
concept is when you
have all the good properties.
A bijection is when you
have exactly one arrow out
and exactly one arrow in.
It's a total function that is
an injection and a surjection
because it's got greater
than or equal to 1
and less than or equal
to 1 and equal to 1
for all of the
domains and codomains.
Now, there's an obvious thing
though about bijections,
which we'll wrap
up with, which is
why they're useful
in counting theory
because it's clear that since
there's exactly one arrow out
of every element in A--
the number of arrows
is the same as the size of A--
and since there's exactly one
arrow coming into every element
of B, the number of arrows
is the same as the size of B.
And guess what.
That means that where
there's a bijection,
the sets are of equal size.
If there's a bijection between
two finite sets A and B,
that means that
they're the same size.